hey everybody welcome to a short
tutorial on how to get good framerate
video if you have a bad frame rate in
your game the short story is I just use
cheat engine to slow down the game and
then speed up the footage in post but
the long story is basically this video
so the first thing you want to do is you
want to download a cheat engine and the
one thing to watch out here is that many
antivirus programs will see it as a
virus even if it isn't but that's
completely fine you can ignore that
message something to watch out for
though is cheat engine wanting to get
you malware on your PC so just skip all
of the message that wants to install you
things that you don't have and after
that's downloaded there is just a simple
installation program where you just want
to let the thing do all of its steps and
you should be completely fine again the
only thing we want to watch out for is
any malware so let's just untick that
and let the Installer do its thing okay
so now that we have cheat engine we want
to open it and the great thing about
this is that the speed hack is actually
relatively easy the first thing we want
to do is go to the top left and click on
this button to select the process that
we want to edit in this case it's planet
coaster and then we can just select it
from the list that it gives us click on
open to make the program open it's and
the next thing we want to do is enable
speed Hank and here we want to set a
value now this is a little bit more
tricky because the value that we want to
set for speed is gonna determine how far
as the game is going to run so for
instance if I put 0.5 over here or slide
the slider over to 0.5 the game is gonna
be 2 times as slow whereas if I put 2
the game is gonna be twice as fast now
in this case for instance because my
game is running at 20 FPS but I want to
record a 60 FPS video I want to slow it
down by about 4 times because I also
want to have a bit of a buffer between
the FPS of my game and the FPS that I'm
recording in to make sure that it's
always recording at 60fps and dropping
frames during the video so all I need to
do to do that is set the speed to 0.25
click apply and the speed of your game
should be much slower and this is
basically how all of it works now you
just want to record whatever you want to
record in the speed to be it a cinematic
shot in city skylines
or an override shown on planet coaster
or especially an unwrite shot of the
coaster in planet coaster
in this state so you actually end up
with a slowed down video and just speed
it up again in post and you should have
a real-time but a good framerate video
now this is where the number of the
speed hack comes in as very important
thing because because I slowed down the
game by four times by setting the speed
to 0.25 I of course want to speed up the
video exactly four times to make sure
that it's actually in real speed again
now before we get into the last part
which is the editing I'm going to
quickly talk a bit about the way that
we're recording the slow down footage
because I usually do it with the X story
OBS is a great for your way to do it but
for some reason it doesn't seem to work
with every single program I know that a
lot of issues are coming up with fraps
I'm not able to record anything with
fraps with cheese engine slowing down my
game and I know that some other people
have this issue as well and while I
haven't tried shadow play or I have
tried shadow play I haven't been able to
get that to work either that doesn't
mean that it necessarily doesn't work
for you
but just keep in mind that not
everything might work when you're
recording a cheat engine slowdown game
I'm not sure what's behind this but it's
just a little thing to note also for
those people who are curious and for
those people who are using OBS to record
my settings just like this I'm recording
in a bitrate of 20,000 higher is good as
well but I wouldn't recommend going much
lower than this video is just 1080p
because I want to make a 1080p video now
FPS is actually not that important in
this case just make sure that once again
once you speed up the video it's in the
right fps we're right to record OBS in
30 FPS right now it wouldn't really
matter either way because I'm gonna
speed up the video in post anyway as
long as you're making sure that your
resolution is good and your encoding in
enough bitrate so that your video is not
gonna become blurry you should be more
or less fine and for any of the more
sophisticated parts of setting up your
OBS there are tons of great YouTube
tutorials on this that are much better
at this than I am now I've got
everyone's favorite program right here
Windows Movie Maker
it's 2009 again but um it actually
allows you to change the speed of the
you can actually just completely finish
off the time-lapse by setting the speed
to four times the regular speed as I
slowed it down four times to get my
framerate good and that's basically
real-time smooth footage done with
pretty much just free tools and random
stuff of course though I'm not saying
you have to do this in Windows Movie
Maker whatever video editing you're
comfortable with works pretty much
anything from premiere to Sony Vegas to
resolve can change the speed of a video
all you have to do is set it to as many
times the speed faster as you slowed it
down with speed engine and that's pretty
much it so thank you guys for watching I
hope you learned something from this and
I have to see you guys sometime soon
[Music]